welcome back to the Rich Eisen show our
in studio audience here in the Honda
studio in Miami given a round of
applause to our guest who is giving
himself a round of applause because he's
the hungriest Player of the Year for the
2019 NFL season as announced by our
friends at Snickers he is Jacksonville
Jaguars quarterback Gardner Minshew how
are you Gardner Mitch I'm good to be
here good to have you here in the flesh
it's not that you got it
what's it like to be Gardner Minshew in
Miami Florida during Super Bowl week
it's not bad you know it's my first time
to ever come to like a Super Bowl or
anything we're getting to meet a lot of
cool people just talk to freaking Barry
Sanders like you know you don't get to
do that every day like it's really cool
experience whoever you met who have you
met at the Super Bowl other than just
here yes I've been you kind of going
around this morning the berry that
Boomer Esiason Carson Palmer Greg
Jennings James Jones a lot of you know
former guys it's really cool to get to
pray for so long and then finally get to
meet but who's in your posse like who's
in your world like you're your are your
friends you're hanging with your friends
are you on wolfing right now
lone wolf oh yeah now I got a couple
buddies coming down I'm working man work
ended so did you get here in the RV no
unfortunately I had to turn in the RV
yesterday what it has happened it's just
a month deal you know with travel camp
in Jacksonville is a month deal month is
up you know and so did you travel the
country in the RV yeah took off
Jacksonville to Mississippi through
Texas duck hunt I went to Austin worked
out in Permian high school from Friday
Night Lights we want to tell you you see
boobie did you see who no I wish okay
yeah we went to Telluride Colorado
incredible place absolutely beautiful to
Las Vegas where I got to fly with Air
Force Thunderbirds which is like now
incredible I've let's pause here yeah
did you pass out oh absolutely
so walk me through that process how did
that work guard yeah what'd you get into
you got into a one of the Thunderbirds
or yeah so it's an f-16 okay and like
you go in in the morning it's like five
hours of prep work they're telling you
what happens like if the prank plane
crashes how to pull your parachute a
monk I don't
this this isn't like let's just not talk
about this but then we go up and it was
absolutely incredible over Las Vegas and
then Death Valley and do all their
tricks and stuff and they just just wear
me out so you passed out you were in
then you come to and you know yeah I
came to as I am gonna play in the plane
after that and that was incredible -
hold on a second
yes you would even you flew the plane
flew the plane like I took it someone
like barrel rolls and like it was unreal
I absolutely like just an experience I
don't get to do are you are you a
trained pilot damn-near basically you
know hey well I mean you know so you're
in this plane and they're like okay
you've got the controls Gardner Minshew
yes what happened take over I got the
thruster right here get a stick and
that's all you really need enough and
now would you what else did you do in
Las Vegas Nevada um yeah just hung out
once a couple shows had a few of my
buddies with me so uh what shows you see
absent that the Caesar's Palace it was
awesome okay as a blast did you did you
go to the Blue Man Group or anything
like that two nights you know the road
trip we were kind of you know we were
moving so here two nights because I bet
you could make a ton of money for
charity to say a weekend with Gardner
Minshew in Las Vegas Nevada you yeah
yeah it's a good idea yeah I mean have
you I mean I guess I I had to go to Las
Vegas I would but yeah for good cause
now obviously you know your draft was
not in Las Vegas Nevada it was last year
and you were sixth round draft choice
did you see what the NFL is planning to
do for the draft this year in DeBlasio
right they're gonna boat people up
they're gonna that's crazy now there are
Chris are there in any town like say Las
Vegas Nevada yes there is a place where
you could wager as to who would actually
wind up in the water
correct correct I'm sure would you have
if you had gotten drafted in Las Vegas
Nevada jumped in the water and would you
do that in the Bellagio fountains God
would have like walked up there it's
like take my picture and then swam off
you know
so I'm off the stage right you don't
want to be wet when you get up there you
swim off and you're good you know that's
next level you know uses for that's like
stuff so you would you would have taken
the conventional boat rod yes you would
have accepted the honor he's selling out
he's boring and then no he swims off
yeah
and how would you have gotten in the
water how would you get in the water
would you um depends how deep it is if
it's deep enough I dive if not a
cannonball cannon I doggy paddle out I
think a dog I cannonball Gardner Minshew
doggy paddle is the greatest way that
you could ever get drafted into the
Nationals no doubt about it all right
and then do you do you have a game of
chance do you do you go to the Jesus you
know I played craps for about four hours
and I still have no clue
like what's going on even but like I got
no clue what's going on that game right
but I got hot hot yeah I was hot
so and then you walk away yeah you got
to walk away up Gardner that's right we
never got up we went we went down
[Laughter]
Gardner Minshew here on the Rich Eisen
sure all right so now you've got some
bling to your right right there on the
right
right-hand part of the chair hmm that is
this that is that what you get for
winning the Snickers hungriest Player of
the Year yeah so when hungriest player
give this chain it's $75,000 okay I know
it's actually gonna be auctioned off and
the fall and the proceeds are gonna go
to Movember okay so cause I'm tied to
it's a great cause you know just men's
health awareness mental health stuff
that like you know macho guys like you
don't want to talk about break but a
stuff that needs to be talked about of
course so just kind of bringing
attention to that certainly when you get
to a certain age men it can't be shy
about checking their bodies for the
cancer and prostate cancer and that
colon cancer I mean the whole idea of
just asking for help just a little bit
wrong with that that's great so the
Movember movement is going to get the
auction off of Gardner Minshew z-- what
do we know what the what diamonds there
are in there what do we know I know it's
valued at a seventy-five thousand that's
a goal that is rich as I years
oh my neck yeah oh my gosh this is you
can swing this around like a nunchuck
and really hurt somebody Wow beautiful
these are like this is diamond encrusted
on there you go very good when you're
when you're not feeling yourself right
you go and have a Snickers hungriest
Player of the Year and what was speaking
of your year did you I mean what a year
it was you look back on the year and you
would think what about what you went
through or what you did what you
accomplished how you handled your
business in Jacksonville what is that
yeah okay first thing is just blessed
man just have the opportunity you know I
think in the path I took there's a lot
of times where it didn't look like I'd
ever come close to that but I think that
all prepared me for this year and you
know it was a big reason why we had the
success that we had at times and what do
you think about next year are you
planning on being the backup going in
have you been told by your coach what
the plan is for 2020 just yeah my plans
to compete and to prove that I'm the guy
you know for the job every day but I
know the Gatton type of got nick is
we've we've talked we had lunch the
other day and we're just excited to get
back to work together I want the best
for him he wants the best for me we're
both gonna work really hard and just try
to make our team better where did you
have lunch
we're that going out of Newports I took
the RV out there and so it was that the
finishing point for your we turned
around and came back yeah you came back
in the or yeah is it cuz you got to
return it to the spine right are you
serious yes
so put about about 7500 miles on it
7500 movin about 17 days and then you
went straight back to we're here in
Florida is that where you started or
were dropped off in Jacksonville Jackson
they drove down here today okay
it drove down here today okay a few more
things for you here Gardner speaking of
mustaches and obviously you've got a
fame mustache we could not help but
notice on your social media account in
your Instagram first minsu mustache for
sale while going through some old
belongings I stumbled upon an artifact
long forgotten what I found was the
first mustache I ever grew in mint
condition NOLA
it's dated from September 3rd 2017 to
October the 10th 2017 you can get a
piece get your hands on this piece of
history for the low low price of 1
million dollars all proceeds will go to
the human front serious enquiries only
very serious and did you get any any
enquiries on this yes still fielding
offers I know what I have so I'm not in
a rush to give it away
no so we're waiting you know the the
seven-digit offers they've been Pao and
and yes the the price is going through
there it goes so you met the act now is
essentially we were yeah you you ought
to but yeah the human fund is very
excited about the donation they're about
three who did you reach out at the human
fund to connect with the UH is my buddy
George yeah say you're friends with the
assistant to the general manager of the
New York Yankees is what yeah that's
right wow you must you meet a lot so he
you know last Christmas I got you know
he donated in my name to the human fund
yes it does I know what kind of guy he
is just such a good cause yeah it's a
great cause there's no doubt about that
and money for people we didn't even we
didn't even mention for the radio
audience that that is a plastic bag in
the lower right hand corner of what is
mustache clippings Carretas hundreds
ampere american mustache it's the only
kind I want no cloning allowed so
there's no cloning allowed there it is
in the lower right
so what other old belongings did you
find well font well well rummaging
through and finding this plastic bag
Humber obviously nothing is noteworthy
as the first mustache okay but I find
all kinds of stuff man I got too much
stuff yeah any that's an issue what's
the oldest pair of George that you own
oh I only have I only ever have one pair
of jorts at a time so like whenever I
get a new like I'll get a new pair every
few years and the old ones are done so
where do you hang them in the rafters
somewhere I mean where do you put the
old ones do you retire them honestly I
I'm not sure where they went
you've got it you've got a whole dozen
one you've got if we don't want I'll
keep my joints I mean if you're gonna
keep your clippings I mean Kalyn that's
just you could sell the shorts the human
fund yeah you could do that too man
and so when when it all does come down
to it when you've got your your your
George Saul handle and you got your
business all handled and you've got
everything all set
what's next man yeah so what's next
what's next for you now Monday I'll move
down to Naples I'll Drive over from then
it's full-time training full-time right
two and a half months that's all I'm
worried about trying to get myself
better so we have a chance to win okay
and that's that's all that's about for
me and you're from the state of
Mississippi right that's where you're
from and your old college coach Mike
Leach is now the coach at Mississippi
State how will Mike Leach fare in the
state of Mississippi - yeah I was
actually the RV didn't make a stop and
start going coach lates yeah but ya know
I've always said like Mississippi State
and Ole Miss they have to do something
different like you're not gonna line up
and beat Alabama heads up you're not
gonna line up and beat LSU heads up you
gotta do something different not
personally I always thought the AIRAID
would be a great fit and I think when he
really gets his guys in there and you
know has everybody bought in I think he
can do you know really good thing did
you see how he came off the plane with
the the cattle warm wasn't great it was
natural yeah it's just like somebody had
it handed to him on the on the plane and
just do you think he looked at and goes
what are you handing me that was really
yeah you know it had nothing to pertain
with what he's doing a wash and set him
right there it's just that's not yeah
what do you think I mean he just walked
just so confused right there looked like
totally confused by that whole thing now
I'm happy for him though man I think him
and their staff awesome people okay
Gardner Minshew you are a national
treasure sir already a great first
season in the pros it was just a blast
to watch you do it and don't be a
stranger when you come out to Los
Angeles come by come by our set you
always got a home that I was actually my
first time in California so is that all
right yeah no kid I'm from Mississippi
don't get
but there was no road games in
California when you played washing it
bit much I mean we just to play yeah so
we played at USC played at Oakland but
didn't really get to enjoy soak around
and what everybody pays so much money
does right yeah you and you're living in
a tax-free State exactly not bad Gardner
Minshew you could again check out what
Snickers is working on next by watching
their new commercial during the Super
Bowl or on their YouTube page and again
congrats again on being the hungriest
Player of the Year for 2019 Gardner
Minshew everybody here on the Rich Eisen
show don't go anywhere say Quan Barkley
and Kurt Warner's still to come for more
of the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app